c'est mon premier amour je pense que je
pas prêt de le lâcher la pulperie de
chicoutimi passionne le professeur
d'histoire jérôme gagnon ce bâtiment
érigé en 1896 et mis en opération en
1897 a été au coeur du développement de
chicoutimi à l'époque l'arrivée de dubuc
à chicoutimi provoque le déménagement
des price à jonquière et c'est le début
d'une longue lutte de pouvoir entre
canadiens français et canadiens anglais
ça prend aussi nécessairement une
dimension je dirais dimension culturelle
canadienne-française les canadiens
anglais qu'on est tapi habitué à voir
contrôler le domaine de l'économie de la
finance
barnard voir arriver des canadiens
français qui eux aussi veulent jouer
dans la cour des grands et monsieur du
butin c'est ce qui va faire à la fin du
19e siècle c'est l'ère des grands
journaux et du papier du buggy qui
possédait des terres à bois avait besoin
d'un endroit pour traiter la pulpe et la
transformer en papier la campagne pub de
chicoutimi c'est pour premièrement
développer l'économie pour sortir un peu
des griffes de william price qui avait
un monopole et
c'est une compagnie aussi ce qui est
nouveau c'est une compagnie canadienne
française donc des gens d'ici qui face à
travailler des gens ici à ce moment
l'église catholique a une influence non
seulement sur les armes mais aussi sur
l'économie de la province
dubuc est un fin stratège et fait appel
à l'architecte qui a imaginé la
cathédrale de chicoutimi pour dessiner
les plans de la pulperie qu on les a
appelés les cathédrales enregistré le
look de l'architecturé est très
majestueux évidemment c'était comme à
l'époque on construira dans ce style là
c'est pour démontrer notre puissance
notre importance on baptisait les usines
du nom de saint joseph sainte marie il y
avait des statuts indigne échoue on
installait des statues de saints pour et
on comprenait très bien qu'on était dans
un environnement qui était catholique
symbole de l'histoire du
saguenay-lac-saint-jean la pulperie sert
maintenant à la raconter elle a été
transformée en musée
dans les années 90 la pulperie est si
grande qu'elle a que un autre bâtiment
la maison de l'artiste peintre arthur
villeneuve
elle a été installée dans un contexte où
où il fallait la sauvegarder
l'oeuvre d'art est unique l'artiste qui
était barbier à chicoutimi racontait sa
vision de la vie sur les murs de sa
maison sa résidence intrigue attiré
inspire petits et grands qui viennent de
partout dans le monde pour un conte
ampli qu on peut nous montrer on peut
rentrer dans l'histoire on peut confier
cette histoire entre la contraint aussi
via la pensée d'un artiste ses
sympathies pour la pensée d'un historien
pas la pensée d'un spécialiste pensée
d'un artiste après avoir abrité pendant
des décennies des travailleurs manuels
la pulperie accueille aujourd'hui des
chercheurs en art en ethnologie et en
archéologie
comme quoi le bâtiment continue à
contribuer à notre espoir
et s'ils me disent c'est reçu les radio
canada saguenay